le sujet de votre émission est la morale
et la pornographie comme monsieur chalet
dans ton c'est tout ce que c'est un
moraliste on sait aussi qu'elle a été le
chemin qu'il a parcouru pour devenir un
moraliste abaisse un sujet à tacen un
chemin facile
alors bon un cinéaste raté quoi nancière
raté un journaliste raté ça devient pas
seulement un moraliste et cette
conversation apparaît mondaine vraiment
allemand merde j'ai envie de changer le
temps j'ai envie de détendre tout ça en
est oui enfin oui je suis là enfin je
suis là enfin vous pouvez regarder
quelqu'un qui exprime naturellement
merde quoi
je suis ravi et je suis ravi madame
abattant des bleus je suis je dit si
vous me donnez envie de faire pipi manal
ici dans ces pays je vous dis j'aime
beaucoup de pays et j'aime les gens en
parlent trop écouté on est à la télé
française
on peut dire merde on peut dire fais
chier [ __ ] de moine et tout montrer
son jeu si vous voulez je vous montre
les spectacles non mais ça m'a parlé
parce que moi je suis là pour parler
sinon merde alors master b vous même